joining me right now is House Minority
Leader Kevin McCarthy and Congressman
it's always a pleasure to see you thanks
for being here thank you for having me
back on so is it necessary to have these
lock downs on obviously the tri-state
area and throughout the country at this
point I think it is necessary because
when you look at the number of deaths
but also the number of individuals have
it a large portion of that is from this
tri-state this president's trying to get
ahead of it just as he made that very
smart decision for stopping the flights
from China coming in as well
these are protections for the rest of
the nation let's talk about that relief
bill that you and your colleagues worked
on the president signing into law can
you go through and walk us through
what's most important and what you
believe will actually move the needle on
economic growth because we know that we
may very well be in a recession right
now this was very critical and it's more
than a rescue it's actually a commitment
from your government I wish we would
have had this a week ago
unfortunately Democrats has held us up
but let's walk through the importance of
this first it provides a hundred and
forty billion dollars to the hospitals
this is directly so they get liquidity
but also for that personal protection
equipment that is so critical because
our medical community is really the
modern-day soldier in this virus that
we're battling but for the small
business owner we want to make sure
we're keeping people employed and if you
were a small business 500 employees to
just a gig worker yourself you get a
guaranteed loan from government for two
and a half times your payroll if you use
that money to pay your employees if you
already laid them off bring them back
and pay them pay your rent pay your
utilities and that is forgiven no longer
alone but a grant if you are a larger
business you get a guaranteed loan but
you also get a retention program in
there through a tax advantage that
government will pay for half of your
employee salary that's an ability to
keep people working then the individual
checks that will go and start in three
weeks twelve hundred dollars per person
2,400 for couple five hundred per child
all right let's start phasing down after
earning $75,000 this is critical to get
us through the next two months and get
this economy coming back just like a
hockey stick looks at will have a couple
but we can have the strongest yeah you
said that yes you said the next two
months and secretary nooshin said the
same thing ten to twelve weeks to
address the dislocation just in the next
10 to 12 weeks so does that mean we're
getting another stimulus a fourth
package after the next 10 to 12 weeks
I'm not sure we need a fourth package
and before before we go to start
drafting a fourth package I'd like these
three packages we just put out remember
it's more than two trillion dollars the
largest we've ever seen to take care and
get this economy moving
remember for unemployment insurance
we're adding another $600 above what
your state pays we start paying in the
first week and we give you additional 13
weeks what concerns me is when I listen
to Nancy Pelosi talk about a fourth
package now it's because she did not get
into things that she really wanted to
change the election law a green new deal
expand it make us pay for Planned
Parenthood and expand what you're seeing
for sanctuary cities those are the
things why this bill was held up for a
week but those are the things that we
stopped that is so outrageous that you
were actually being asked to consider
funding Planned Parenthood at a time
that we are in this crisis situation
where you're trying to come up with a
relief package I just want to share with
you what Nancy Pelosi said this morning
though congressman because she is just
saying this right now president Trump's
denial at the beginning of this was
deadly and that right now as he fiddles
her words as he fiddles people are dying
this is what Nancy Pelosi said this
morning
your reaction well what I see is that
Nancy is trying to cover herself in the
Democratic Party because the amount of
damage that they had just done in the
last week requesting about changing
election law that her number three in
her own party said they wanted to
restructure government take the
opportunity of a crisis and Maria what
happened last week 3.2 million Americans
lost their job six times higher than in
the financial crisis higher than the
Great Depression all because Democrats
wanted to put their liberal parts in but
this president fought for it
this president stopped that and what's
most importantly as history will not be
kind to the Democrats holding up that
week was so critical when you look at
the action that President Trump took the
one of the first to stop that the
Chinese would be coming into America our
Europe as well and their own party
criticized the president for doing those
actions but it saved thousands of lives
just as he wanted to move this bill I
was sitting in that meeting last Sunday
this bill is 99% where it was last
Sunday but Nancy Pelosi held it up
bragged to her members in the idea of
changing green New Deal Planned
Parenthood changing election law and
expanding sanctuary cities nothing to do
with coronavirus they did get 2014 write
about more dollars for the Kennedy
Center yes
exactly 25 million for the Kennedy
Center and yet she tells a completely
different story you know this you know
that she said that she did jujitsu on
the plan she said we had to do jujitsu
to change it to me to get it where it is
and then of course you've got Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez and what she said on
Friday
watch this gotta get your reaction
congressman what did the Senate majority
fight for one of the largest corporate
bailouts with as few strings as possible
in American history shameful the greed
of that fight is wrong you saw that your
reaction yes well it's not a time for
theatrics this is time to actually get
the bill done but if you listen to these
Democrats that is exactly what they want
to do they're more
earned about a foreign country or
foreign individual than they are about
America themselves and not only do we
have to fight this remember the virus is
here we did not invite it we did not ask
for it but we will defeat it together
and that's exactly what this bill does
unfortunately we were held up a week by
the Democrats ninety nine percent of
this bill was done last week it's
exactly the same from the thirteen extra
weeks from the small business from the
large business from the hospitals but
Pelosi is in trouble
based upon hurting Americans because
they want to restructure this to look
more like the socialist views they
believe in so let's end on some optimism
Conklin because I know that you had a
phone call this morning with with
managers of businesses CEOs in the
pharma sector tell us what you're
expecting and this feels like a newfound
partnership between business and
government right now I know that the
president has been calling lots of
different groups CEOs to the White House
to try to figure out how business can
can help here what have you learned this
is the great thing about America the
ingenuity I was talking to a consortium
from the very best medical individuals
to the very highest CEOs working
together with government to get that
personal protection equipment coming
into America and as we know China has
gotten a large portion of that supply
chain unfortunately we just found out
one of the highest CEOs told me that she
came in and took one of our factories
where we were purchasing millions of the
equipment to come over here to give it
to France because they're trying to take
more of the market share for wall way
that France will agree to allow wall way
into their industry once again from the
from the equipment to using this this
tragic situation to get more of the
supply chain in another industry but
what we're seeing in America look at
what Abbott just came out this week that
they have a new ability to get a test
results for coronavirus in as fast as
five minutes we're already into a trial
one test for a virus with the ingenuity
of America will overcome this we will be
stronger but we have to look at the
supply chain something that President
Trump has told us about from the very
beginning
China has too much control of our
medical equipment too much
control when it comes to pharmaceuticals
too much control of critical minerals
we've got to take this back and keep it
inside America so we can we can combat
not only this but other things in the
future definitely one of the most
important lessons from all of this House
Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy good to
see you sir thanks so much